Yo, do you know that there's, uh,
speakers that you for? If you're pregnant,
you could put a speaker in your vagina and play music for the baby.
That's a thing. That's something. And, and then,
and the baby can hear music and just supposed to like calm the baby and stuff
like this. And that's a product and doctors are like, Hey,
don't use it idiots. Do you know why?
Because you should never put electronics up inside your. Does,
is that something that needs to be said, Hey,
don't put electronics in your Plessy.
Do you know why electronics?
Imagine that. Just putting a being so dumb that you're like, Oh,
I got to buy that and put music up my.
So my unborn child can listen to Josh Groban.
Imagine, do you turn it on first and then put it in?
Or do you put it in and then turn on it?
How do you even know if it's it's playing? It's just like, it's just like,
I, here we go. Here we go. We'll turn on.
You raise me up in this
mountain and then used to get it.
[inaudible] it's kind of funny. Take it out a little bit. [inaudible] up.
To it. That's so,
what other in your put you're just in line and Starbucks.
What the is that coming from? Is that this top now, but it's muffled.
And then that's the commercial. And then the girl looks over and says,
it's my speakers. My son's going to be musical.
Just what's that. Or maybe it's like a, uh,
what's this song or this song. It's probably a.
[Inaudible].
Dude, Alvin and the chipmunks, you know?
Yeah.
Dude. There's speakers. What do you call them? I don't even know.
We got to do that. Why do you listen to this podcast?
Talking about puts his finger.
All there's so many electronics and, baby. What?
Baby pod. It's called you. Stick them in your, in you.
Can you put it baby pod?
Let's look this up baby pod. Oh,
it was on the Ellen show. Come on Ellen. Oh,
baby pod is a device for sharing music with your baby for stimulating baby's
development during pregnancy. Hey, you know, what's fine, dude. Not doing that.
You know, it's fine. Just letting your baby gestate in your pacy.
Music stimulates the baby before birth. No, it doesn't.
This is a scientific fact. No says who,
but how to convey the musical stimulus in the same way that we cannot hear what
is going on inside the baby cannot hear what is happening outside.
And that's fine. This is also a fact, the soft tissues absorb and scatter sound
only from within.
We can stimulate the baby 3d ultrasound scans demonstrate this
once your child, the baby, the inside the baby don't take dockets.
Okay.
It's just like all fast and. Like a horror movie. Only funky.
Folks and encourages a response. The miracle of phonation starts prematurely.
I mean two key to cognitive development. Are you kidding me,
baby sticks out its tongue. Oh wow. And you can't.
Sticks out his tongue when the music's on, like it's playing Axl Rose.
The bass is like that.
Hmm.
Oh my God. Dude.
Imagine being that much of an idiot that you get a baby pod and stick it in your
put and then that too.
You play that. I would get Bluetooth and up and try and try to,
um, hook in and make their baby listen to like this.
All of a sudden [inaudible]. That's fine. Wait
to talk to your child to tell your baby how much you love him and see how he
reacts. Shut up, dude. What if you could start now, I
got a USB with the umbilical cord. Give your baby a universal stimulus. Send him a message from before birth.
Giving your baby a universal stimulus. You know what it is?
Life.
That's the most universal stimulus, Hugh product.
Make sure it reaches your child. I mean, come on, dude. Stimulus.
What if you could start now
give your baby a universal stimulus.
Send him a message from before birth and make sure it reaches your child.
Come on, dude.
Dude, they have an instruction.
They have a little thing that they're holding and then it shows the person
inserting it in their vagina. And then it shows a phone opening the,
the music app and then plugging in headphones. Hot.
It's a crash dude.
Bluetooth music inside your to your baby.
[Inaudible] guys would get this and put it in there. But
talk to your shift.
Music is not life. Life is life.
Let the baby just have life and then let it choose what music is.
I imagine it was a meat dude. Imagine it was,
I imagine, well, you don't want to mute, but measure a down South in your life.
Ah, put up,
play a Travis Tritt for the little critter and then you put it in your and it's
just like some. And it's just like me. I'm like,
I hate country music. And for nine months,
you're just listening to home. I'm mom on.
Change.
You just listened to Travis Tritt. Great day to be alive. You know,
You're just some baby. Come on.
[Inaudible] down on my house.
And you got to hear that as a baby dude.
Let's look up how to use baby pod. How to use
baby pod. How to use,
okay, here we go. How do you use newborns? Uh, how do you baby?
Moon pod? No, no, no, no, no, no.
You should look up the video or just uh, all right.
How to use. Oh, got it. Okay, baby pod.
What is B? I'll go to baby pod.com. Don't get this. Okay.
Because doctors would obviously not want this. Here we go. Baby.
pod.com. Isn't baby cut.
Maybe pod.com.net
light one fire pod.net.
Uh, it's very easy to start. Oh,
why is it in Spanish for me? Oh, here we go. How to use?
It's very easy to start. Get into a comfortable position.
Number one,
gently insert the free end of baby pod until it's inside the vagina.
Well, obviously you're not going to put the phone in there. The free end,
insert the phone part into your. Make sure it's on airplane mode.
So you don't get a call
number to connect the Jack plug into your smartphone.
If you want to sh number three,
if you want to share the music your baby is listening to.
There is another audio input on the top of the connector for your headphones.
I mean, is it for the baby or what you, you you're like? Well,
I want to listen to number four says selfish, you know,
number four to remove your baby pod, just pull gently on the connection cord or
make a, make a bowel movement move that's so
absolutely asinine baby pod hygiene
here under it. There is none it's in your policy and that's gross, uh,
recommendations and cautions.
Remember that cleaning baby pod to assure hygiene is essential before and after
each use with baby pod closed, clean the outside of the mild soap and water.
Yeah. Okay. Do not submerge your baby pot under water. I mean,
if you can't submerge it under water, you shouldn't put it in your. Huh?
That's a good,
that's a good rule to clean the inside of your baby pod. Open it.
Clockwise warning. Here's a warning.
Avoid the inside part connected to the cable, getting wet. Oh,
that's a hardly a warning. They got to.
Why is it in Spanish here?
Oh, it's made in Mexico. That's how you know it's good.
Baby pod, a speaker that's inserted into the vagina,
like a tampon and then connected to a music player.
A fetus is protected by amniotic fluid, a membrane,
the uterine wall and the vaginal wall.
Distorted audio can pass through these layers by the developers of the baby pod
say research shows clear sound to the womb is only possible via the vagina,
the button.
So really researchers at baby pod say that,
nah, that's weird that they're researchers of baby pod.
Say that baby pod works say
criminals.
Barcelona based designers of the device, the Institute market.
Oh man. Imagine buying something from Barcelona. For real. That's not food.
Commands using baby pod after the 16th week and for a maximum recommends using
baby pod. After the 16th week,
a maximum of 20 minutes each time we don't want your baby
starting to headbang.
Pop volume is 54 decibels users of the device offered
testimonials saying ultrasounds.
V these like animated, like people on the,
on this video, they're not,
they don't even have a real actors doing this because they know like real actors
would be like, what the? What the are we doing? This is horrible.
Hold on.
And show their babies appear to move their mouths or respond to music coming
from and inserted. Baby pod,
baby costs around 160 us dollars to music prominent
saying ultrasound scan,
show their babies appear to move their mouths or respond to music coming from
and inserted. Baby pod, baby pod costs around 160 us dollars.
And parents can listen to the same sounds as their baby by using split
headphones, which hang out of the vagina.
Dude, this is real.
Imagine that listening to music and you were plugged into your own
vagina, dude,
what the? This is something that would,
this is something that would be like something in like the early nineties,
but there were no smartphones in the early nineties.
So Barcelona is catching the up.
I just can't believe someone would really buy this.
I gotta do ads. This is.
Wild. Add baby pod. So.
Have you guys ever had a baby? Well guess what? You can listen to your,
you can listen to music with your baby and all you have to do is insert baby
part into your. And for now, right on,
all you gotta do is go to baby pod.com/congrats,
and you can get the speakers next. Um, I need to start doing that,
dude. It's, I'm really dropping the ball with dress, like a.
And I'm not talking about like ASAP Rocky and fashion week.
I'm talking about like a leveling it, the up like just a Marvel character.
Like what the, who is he? And I just am,
and I got the baby pot in my and you could, and it's this.
Hmm.
And I switch it. And every time I, if I steal your girl
In my, my S my bit of baby potty in my.
And then if you talk and I talk back quick.
[Inaudible].
And then if I'm just chilling, having a good time in my,
and then if goes on and I start to level up.
[Inaudible].
And then if, and then when I, whenever I'm.
Am I, dude, do you understand this is a family friendly podcast and, um,
I want you to listen to it with your real actual babies.
And then I want this in my, no problem. Just here. My,
um.
You know what Shannon sharp sounds like. They're like he's under water.